natürlich denken viele menschen noch
immer dass man als influenza überbezahlt
ist aber man muss auch bedenken
man muss sehr viel privatsphäre her
ergeben
weil freunde ich bin gerade mit dem
kamerateam heute unterwegs wenn wir
drehen etwas fürs zdf
mein name ist marco ich bin 19 jahre alt
und ich bin influenza
[Musik]
mit der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
verbinde ich eigentlich so komplett
meine ganze kindheit 2002 geboren sie
hantiert seit 2005 also ich bin mit
dieser frau aufgewachsen
[Musik]
die meisten follower habe ich momentan
auch tickt da habe ich 2,3 millionen
follower instagram da habe ich um die
450.000 dollar und youtube habe ich 70
tausend follower influenza ist man schon
ab 20.000 abonnenten auf youtube aber
einige sagen auch meine sind für unser
ab dem punkt wo man eben geld verdienen
kann damit geld das influenza verdienst
zu quasi damit indem ich bestimmte
werbepartner anschreiben sich eben nach
einer kooperation fragen und dafür
bekommst du natürlich dann auch eine
gewisse gage in dem du zum beispiel
diesen post für diese firma macht
[Musik]
den einfluss den ich durch diese
reichweite ich habe es mir auf jeden
fall bewusst für die jüngeren leute
versuche ich auch vorbild zu sein leben
zum beispiel mich für themen selbst die
noch sehr stark von der gesellschaft
eben nicht beachtet werden und sind
gerade im jungen alter ist es ja oft so
dass sich menschen einfach um gefühlen
in ihrem körper oder so und gemobbt
werden deswegen und da versuche ich dann
einfach mobil zu sein versucht diesen
leuten klarzumachen dass es egal ist die
großen welche hautfarbe du hast egal
welche sexualität du hast du ein
bisschen bis ein bisschen dünner das ist
weil ich egal du bist du und sowieso
perfekt
[Musik]
hat sich von den kielern 20 jahre hatte
ich bin der beste freund von marco und
zu schützen auch mit allem so hat sich
auch schon zu sexueller schon so
wirklich sag mal böse texte gelesen von
anderen leuten muss ich die leute so
beleidigt hat oder hat man
ja ich muss meine reichweite natürlich
auch und gerade hass im netz einfach ein
bisschen abzuschaffen sozusagen oder
auch für die öbb die kussszenen oder
black gleisbett und ich zum beispiel ich
hatte damals auch so eine zeit in der
schule wo halt eben auch viel mit
henzler am morgen zu tun hatte und
seitdem bin ich da eigentlich so in
dieser einstellung dass ich halt eben
sagt ich möchte diesen menschen die da
betroffen sind einfach helfen das aber
natürlich gibt es auch dann immer wieder
gerade wenn es zum beispiel mehr
reichweite bekommen dieses bild dann
gibt's natürlich immer menschen die
sagen dass so etwas nicht normal ist
oder die alten versuchen da eben dieses
negative wieder quasi als richtig zu
sehen also kommt natürlich ganz ganz oft
bei solchen beiträgen vor aber ich sag
mal so schön ich stehe darüber weil es
einfach wichtig dass man sich dafür
einsatz
auch wenn es nur ein paar hundert
menschen sind die ich da quasi umstimmen
kann und eben auf den richtigen weg
gleichen kann dass hass im netz nicht
korrekt ist
von der politik wünsche mir dass gerade
dieser hass der im netz verbreitet wird
viel härter bestraft wird als das was
nur gelöscht wird quasi von den
plattformen denn ich finde das einfach
nicht okay man macht damit menschen
kaputt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir bereiten gerade so ein kleines vor
weil wir sind ja dann morgen im
europapark und da haben wir so geplant
dass wir eine achterbahn sitzen und dann
eben mit der kamera ist zum beispiel mit
dem handy aber ich weiß noch nicht ob es
erlaubt dass ich hoffe natürlich dass
wir da eben so ein kleines achterbahn
kurs machen weil ich glaube so was gab's
auf tik tok oder generell auf social
media noch nie
abgeholt wir haben noch kurz was zu
trinken gekauft und jetzt geht
[Applaus]
das ist jetzt in den europapark endlich
mal wieder kam bedeutete mir natürlich
irgendwo sehr viel denn ich das war
meine kindheit ich bin damit
aufgewachsen
und jetzt auf jeden fall übertrieben
kraft laufen kann sich kaum erwarten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die für heute soweit fertig mit drehen
die haben uns hier sogar noch die gopro
hier gelassen dann können wir auch so
ein bisschen mit film und das genießen
wir noch die letzten eineinhalb stunden
die wir noch haben hier
nicht immer ganz so einfach mal die
leute wie das verfolgen so in echt zu
sehen weil man hat ja - diese accounts
bei augen- und dann möchte ich mal
endlich mal ganz ruhig heute das ist
heftig hier
hallo
[Applaus]
da ich das ja in der öffentlichkeit
stehen auch gleichzeitig meine mutter
und meine schwester in der
öffentlichkeit wenn wir zum beispiel
manchmal unterwegs sind in der stadt
oder so dann werden sie natürlich auch
manchmal kennt fragt zum beispiel
mädchen bist du nicht die mutter von
marco oder anfangs war das natürlich für
die alle auch neuland aber mittlerweile
dem sie damit auch ganz offen oben zum
beispiel wenn wenn ich auch liebe grüße
ausrichten soll oder so dann freut sich
das natürlich auch immer auch meine
schwester mama die machen auch immer
ganz
so
[Musik]
wie man zum zeigte bilder sind die
aufrufe wird wieder platziert aber ich
mache jetzt also heute wieder im bild
wahrscheinlich muss ich aber noch
überlegen was ich ja am besten macht
also wenn ich mir ein herzenswunsch
dass italien verspielt da kann ich
richtig tolle platte machen
[Musik]
also mit influenza konnte ich am anfang
gar nichts anfangen aber jetzt bitte
zeigt ja es macht ihn glücklich und ja
ich bin richtig stolz auf ihn
[Musik]
ich fahre sehr guten story dass meine
zuschauer auf wissen wo ich gerade bin
also dass ich mit meiner familie
bisschen zeit genau
durch meine liebe zu meiner mama am 1
meine schwester und ja wir können uns
jetzt hier erstmal ein bisschen
abteilungsleiter
hier kannst du musst du
natürlich denken viele menschen auch
immer dass man als influenza überbezahlt
das aber man muss auch bedenken
man muss sehr viel privatsphäre her
ergeben was man eben eigentlich nicht
wirklich tun würde aber ich kann man
muss sagen ich bin damit aufgewachsen
quasi dass ich mein privatleben teile
und deswegen bin ich damit auch völlig
okay aber es ist natürlich für viele
immer ein sehr schweres thema
bleiben der große ging von 18 jährige
auf jeden fall viel geld aber solang es
spart und die produkt ist es für mich
ganz ok
[Musik]
also moderiert jetzt ja jeden tag im
alltag was er alles machen ins wasser
als leicht also es ist schon man sieht
es von außen nicht aber wenn man dann
mit drin ist ist schon viel gehört aber
man weiß halt nicht wie lange kann von
jetzt ist man halt zu ende gehen und
heutzutage ist ein versuch wäre ist
einfach wichtig dann auch mal ja wenn es
einfach keinen tick tock mehr gibt kein
instagram mehr wie geht es mit social
media weiter läuft es gut oder läuft es
nicht gut daher möchte ich auch die
nächsten jahre auf jeden fall noch eine
ausbildung absolvieren meine mama hat
mich da wirklich schon seit beginn auf
darauf vorbereitet war sie hat gesagt
ich soll mein geld sparen so hab ich
lieben gelernt
diesen perfekt
wir
wissen dass hier fertig wir sind jetzt
alle klatschnass irgendwie wir haben uns
noch ein bisschen nass gemacht und jetzt
gehen wir wieder oder mal schauen wann
[Musik]
ich wo momentan noch bei meinen eltern
zu hause meine geschwister sind schon
ausgezogen ich wohne mit meiner mama und
meinem papa
da man kann immer sagen man wünscht sich
normales leben aber ich sehe das so das
ist mein leben so ich bin da
reingerutscht und ich finde es
eigentlich relativ cool so wie es
momentan ist klar irgendwann geht es
natürlich so weit werden die leute zum
beispiel schon vor der haustür stehen
oder deine handynummer irgendwie
herausfinden und dich anrufen und ich
belästigen
von der neuen bundesregierung würde ich
mir natürlich auch er wünschte dass sie
gerade in der schule auch mehr dieses
thema politik mit einbinden denn gerade
ich zum beispiel muss ehrlich zugeben
ich in der schule hatte nicht viel mit
politik zu tun und dadurch ist mir auch
schwer jetzt in diesem zeitraum quasi
über diese politik bescheid zu wissen so
richtig denn eigentlich sollte man
einfach mehr in der schule quasi an
stoffs beibringen
[Musik]
die wahlen stehen natürlich wäre das ja
auch das erste mal aber ich möchte meine
reichweite gar nicht so krass für nutzen
dass die leute sich für eine gewisse
partei oder so weiter und so weiter
entscheidend weil ich finde jeder sollte
da seine eigene meinung haben sogleich
geht halt vielleicht mal denkanstöße und
sagt es ist wichtig dass ich in der
partei auch für die menschenrechte
einsetzt und dass es denen nicht
komplett egal ist und aber so gezielt
auf eine partei quasi wo ich sage zählt
diese partei dass er so gar nicht meins
und wenn hier noch mehr von generation
merkel sehen wollt dann schaut jetzt
mediathek vorbei
[Musik]